[Música]
y
más tarde
recientemente las autoridades sauditas
dieron inicio a una amplia operación de
demolición en diferentes barrios de yeda
la segunda ciudad más grande de arabia
saudita el objetivo es dar paso a un
megaproyecto urbanístico denominado
sierra central cuyo valor está estimado
en más de mil millones de euros y el
cual va a contar con una ópera un
acuario un museo y hoteles de lujo el
problema es que muchas familias afirman
no haber sido notificadas a tiempo y
fueron expulsadas sin ningún tipo de
compensación en un país en donde la
expresión no es del todo libre nadie se
atreve a rechazar oa criticar esta
decisión abiertamente mohamed es un
habitante de yeda nos cuenta sus
testimonios de manera oculta por
seguridad
no
se ven excavadoras por todas partes
destruyendo todo a su paso es como un
cáncer empezó en el sur de la ciudad
hace cuatro meses y se está extendiendo
hacia el centro histórico hasta ahora se
han demolido unos diez barrios unos 40
barrios están afectados y deberían
quedar completamente arrasados a finales
de año
las autoridades no han puesto los medios
suficientes para que las familias serán
reubicadas los servicios municipales
pusieron advertencias en las fachadas de
algunos edificios y si la gente no se
iba les cortaban la electricidad y
tiraban sus pertenencias
télam
[Música]
el gobierno anunció haber reubicado a
algunas familias pero ciertamente no son
la mayoría los activistas calculan que
casi 800.000 personas han sido
desplazadas por lo que es imposible que
haya viviendas disponibles para todas
ellas adele llama catmull la web llama
la mirada fija de tatiana carrier hay
familias que se fueron a vivir a los
pueblos de los alrededores en mi
edificio hay un apartamento con tres
familias apiñadas porque la gente no
encuentra dónde vivir afortunadamente
existe esa solidaridad estos barrios se
construyeron en el sur de yeda hace casi
70 años de forma un poco anárquica la
mayoría de los extranjeros de origen
modesto se establecieron a y al mismo
tiempo había una próspera economía del
barrio hoy en día muchas personas se
encuentran sin trabajo
acá en hallar levas
modernizar la ciudad sí pero no a costa
de los ciudadanos
las autoridades sauditas anunciaron el
pasado mes de enero que las familias
desalojadas que tuvieran títulos de
propiedad serían indemnizadas sin
embargo no especificaron un calendario
para recibir estas compensaciones
[Música]
la guerra continúa en ucrania pero las
alertas de ataques aéreos no siempre son
fiables y no siempre son difundidas en
internet por esta razón un estudiante
estadounidense en israel decidió
proponer una solución creando una
herramienta de alerta en línea que imita
el sistema de notificación de alertas
que tiene israel su proyecto permite
tanto a los ucranianos en el extranjero
estar conectados con sus seres queridos
como a los que siguen en ucrania estar
plenamente informados de las amenazas
rusas así es como funciona en realidad
no hay una forma convincente de alertar
a la gente cuando suena una sirena del
sistema actual está bloqueado y es
específico para cada zona así que si uno
tiene familiares en esa zona pero no
está ahí físicamente no puede ver
realmente si las sirenas están sonando
shairon alerta o sea es una plataforma
que alerta automáticamente a la
población de los ataques y los convierte
en un mapa con información sobre la
alerta en donde se encuentra la hora y
la fecha
estos datos en twitter telegram facebook
y pronto también difundirá la alerta por
sms y por correo electrónico
digamos que un avión acaba de despegar
de las luces
[Música]
el ejército informará a los municipios y
ciudades pueden verse afectados y luego
estas áreas públicas las alertas ones en
sus cuentas de redes sociales o sitios
web
[Aplausos]
o sea combina todos esos datos en un
solo lugar he contactado personas de
ucrania y de fuera de ucrania uno de
ellos que me impactó mucho se llama quiz
y es de quien me dijo que se enteró del
proyecto por twitter que lo utilizaba
porque la zona en la que estaban las
sirenas
así que usaba agua es sea porque le daba
alertas sobre su zona aunque no hicieran
las físicas allá esto le permite
avisarles a sus amigos y familiares me
dijo que eso le ayudó y salvo a su
familia y eso me parece increíble ese es
mi objetivo empecé el proyecto porque
quiero ayudar a la gente
llegamos al final de este episodio de
los observadores de france 24 como
siempre no duden en comunicarse con la
producción del programa para hacer sus
denuncias o contarnos sus historias de
relevancia todos nuestros puntos de
contacto aparecen en sus pantallas
esperamos todas sus fotos y sus vídeos
queremos agradecer a k fedelatín tería
en chapinero en bogotá por haber sido
nuestra locación el día de hoy nosotros
nos vemos la próxima semana hasta pronto